we're getting a jump on the celebration
for national
water park day that's coming up tomorrow
and it's the perfect time
for some refreshing family fun rocky
thea stopped by cowabunga bay
to see how they're celebrating and what
they have to offer
are getting a head start celebrating
national water park day with the owner
of cowabunga bay that everyone loves so
much shane thank you for having us here
thank you it's such a beautiful day for
the water park perfect weather isn't it
yes
i probably have a max tan okay let's
face it but okay so everybody's coming
down right now
on this slide introduce us to this bad
boy this is our surfing usa mat racer
slide it's strictly face first
downhill starting from a point of about
50 feet
and it's time so each one of the lanes
has a
time clock that starts them the race is
on right now
okay so this slide is obviously for the
big leagues but you mentioned earlier
that there's a mini one right that
kids can try out before they get on here
oh yeah cowabunga bay is not only fun
for these guys but we have a miniature
version called cowboy kids cove
that has this exact same slide scaled
down for the little ones i love that
obviously you guys
are there's something for everyone here
and how are we celebrating national
water park day tomorrow and beyond i
know you guys have a lot going on this
weekend coming up
i know tomorrow is officially national
water park day with this heat it seems
like every day should be waterpark day
but we have all kinds of things going on
this weekend we have our friday special
which is free parking and free sodas
and saturdays is fireworks so we're open
till nine over the weekend
that's so much fun you guys can come
here during the day or during the night
a little different vibe obviously
family fun but date night whatever
whatever you need you can do it here let
me tell you when the sun goes down it's
perfect temperature so come out after
four stay till nine
i love that and we're looking at the
drink line right now and i smell hot
dogs so tell everybody what else they
can enjoy here
besides the slides the pools and the
lazy river we've got beer wine
foot long hot dogs funnel cakes hand
dipped corn dogs
pizza chicken strips you know everything
that
is not good for you but is great for you
i think fun is good for you no matter
what right
okay so tell everybody about your season
passes and just how they can come enjoy
half a season for half a price right now
it's good any day through the end of
september
all right you guys come on down
celebrate national water park day and
just
life in general you are invited to
calabanga bay i'll send it back to you